recording does it show anything like
this okay
yeah the cycle is pretty good yeah I can
hear you guys can you guys hear me okay
yeah okay yeah closer that you get to
the microphone computer microphones or
inventory ously you know not the best
but that's not a most co-authors most
co-authors you know barely talk to each
other after the book good to see you
guys are so cozy so tell me where are
you guys right now as I'm speaking with
Jorge Cham and Danny White's and authors
of the fantastic but this is gonna
become a collector's item soon because
this is the hardcover yes we at the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination are delighted to be hosting
an event on May 8 2008 een which has a
bunch of your paperbacks oh hey what are
you guys up to and we're gonna talk a
lot about the book I know you guys are
pressed for time you're doing a bunch of
media tours but tell me what's going on
brings you guys to New York City yeah
we're here this week to we give a talk
at the net American Museum of Natural
History yesterday at the Hayden
Planetarium
fun but we do know Neil deGrasse Tyson
we did not mean you
although we walk past as often as we did
any closer cost you a lot of money but
then we're also doing a pi day event at
address obscura which is a great kind of
science outreach organization Rainier
know at Columbia also the science series
they're called science on the Hudson
these great science communities they've
built in traveling around we found that
a lot of places have really done the
work over the years to build a community
of people in the public interested in
science and when you build that
community with a series of lectures then
they can be really responsive and places
where they haven't done that yet it's
much harder to reach the people who are
interested in this kind of stuff because
the community
hasn't formed great examples are like in
Saturday morning physics lectures
they've made like hundreds and hundreds
of people show up on a Saturday morning
freezing cold to talk about physics yeah
it's great when these local communities
come together excited about science
learning about new books and stuff yeah
it's the hard work of the local
organizers who spent all that time
building these communities and these
networks and it's impressive so we just
use them well you're gonna be having an
opportunity to shill the paper back when
you're here because you just described
exactly what we do here at the arthur c
clarke center so we have a you know
lectures we have this podcast which is
the only one of the few podcasts within
the university of california that i'm
aware of and we have public lectures and
events where we bring in scientists
science fiction authors we've had Sir
Roger Penrose was just here a month ago
Freeman Dyson I just did an interview
with him so we're gonna we're gonna
bring together some of those in the
conversation that we have today and then
when you're here on May 8th for the book
looking forward to that wonderful
looking forward to a wonderful event so
I want to talk to you guys first about
your day jobs and then you know we'll
get into the writing and the
collaborative process that you guys have
have have turned out so well really a
unique book in many ways I mean there
have been books written about about
science by you know by you know comic or
authors and there have been science
books written by scientists with no you
know with dry illustrations but you know
rarely has been you know where two
scientists have gone together and done a
work of creative you know graphic art
the way that this is and I wanted to you
know first get it get a background on
the two of you individually so so Jorge
you're originally from Panama which I
believe is is correct yes so they're yep
that's right I was born in Panama and
then I studied up here in the US all
right you got your PhD fast enough yeah
that's right and but then what happened
was while I was getting my PhD in
robotics I started drawing comics I
started dressing you called PhD comments
about higher and deeper and yeah
as I said of kept going the cat I
couldn't make track the comics kind of
became more popular than the research I
was doing and so that's what I do now
comics and writing and projects and as I
understood it the comic sort of took off
virally you weren't trying to sell it or
market it or anything originally it just
spread by word of mouth around campuses
what do you think made it so appealing
to to your fellow students you must been
speaking the truth well I think that we
had the power of comic surface you know
it kind of portrays the truth or tourism
you know are maybe people are instead of
open to talk about openly so I think
yeah I think that's what people
connected to is this idea that here's
somebody writing about the academic
process but in and maybe slightly
reverent way or in a way that was kind
of funny you know adding humor to
academia where I think was not a
necessarily a natural combination making
fun of professor's making [ __ ] Daniel
don't worry but I mean it's kind of you
capture in the in the strip I mean
sometimes I've even heard you compare
yourself to you know Scott Adams Dilbert
but in a way I mean yours is it's very
highbrow in a sense and it's very
existentially sometimes full of of the
dread and ennui that that students and I
remember you know what it was like to be
aggressive but I mean I have to ask was
your grad student experience you know
anything like that which you depict but
the character that yeah no I mean
there's definitely I think the core the
strip is sort of that question is like
why would a really intelligent and
rational person pursue an academic
career you know it's not necessarily the
most highest paid job out there and
there's a lot of you know challenges and
in terms of in terms of coming up with
ideas and making ideas working and
there's kind of this big built-in
uncertainty you know you never know the
science working on is gonna pay off or
you never know
the project working on is actually gotta
work so yeah I think that's what people
gotta try to to end definitely it was my
experience you know kind of going to
grad school I thought I was pretty smart
but they know you're certainly in a
really release extra smart people and so
yeah and just kind of going through that
ego check and going through the bed kind
of realization of your limits really you
know and also just the kind of funny
dynamics in it in in academia I think
but they just relatable and what do you
find is it more is it more challenging I
mean the the thing that I remember most
about you know all the academic levels
starting from undergraduate to graduate
to postdoc to assistant professor your
social cohort kind of decreases you know
exponentially at each level and I wonder
you know
are you working nowadays in isolation
are you I mean besides a collaboration
with Daniel are you or do you mainly
work by yourself and if so how do you
how do you handle those kind of you know
different different environments as
opposed to grad school where you've got
at least a lot of people are suffering
around you yeah I think you know there's
people around in grad school but it's
very isolating experience you know it's
like it's you and your advisor and be
nobody else in the world knows what
you're working on in a specific level
and what kind of certainties are on your
project and so I think I think academia
is even though you're surrounded by
people you'd still very kind of
isolating experience yeah and there's a
lot of parallels but cartooning you know
I still work in my pajamas closely late
late at night and things like that I
enforce a strict no pajamas role in the
lab but we could commiserate about you
know what it was like to be a graduate
student but but I think it might be
interesting to get I mean what about
Jorge's comics in the movie in which the
what
in which the comics are comic strip on
which the movie was based on and I
understand there's the second second
version of that so what is it like being
on the other side of the desk you know
kind of Jorge always depicts you know
the grad student and then the wise you
know bearded white hair if you don't
have the white hair you've got the white
son the young the white hair
so yeah with tenure comes you know
massive hair suit achill privileges so
what's it like for those you know the
uninitiated what's it like to be a real
professor as I think it's the best job
in the world honestly I mean I just get
to think about questions that are
interesting to me mostly I think about
other questions and then spin them off
to my students and grads and postdocs
who take them and actually run with them
and execute them I think it's a lot of
fun it's a great freedom great
intellectual freedom
nobody needs telling me what to do every
day you know and I get to goof off on
side projects if I want this fantastic
collaboration from Cory hey so I had no
idea when I was in grad school when I
was an undergrad what being a professor
was like but I'm pretty glad I went down
this road mm-hmm
so both of you guys I think what is a
hallmark for both of you fellows is that
you're both great storytellers I've had
the opportunity to see Daniel live and
in person and we're looking forward to
your event here in May a and I've seen
Jorge I've seen your TED talk and so
forth what what about that commonality I
mean do you think I mean not mostly
Daniel professors are depicted as you
know pretty dry boring you know erudite
but intellectually yet you know
unintelligible how do you I mean did you
did you take any training is there
anything that you did in your career you
know to accentuate the extroverted
aspect of your personnel because I mean
we both know not every every professor
may share that the delightful things
that we enjoy about academia but they're
not always good at pointing out to the
public it's such a elucidated
easy fashion is here what what you know
what do you attribute that to
I think it takes a lot of practice
honestly and I think people don't
recognize that and you're right
professors we don't get much training or
practice but when I was in high school I
did a lot of debating an extemporaneous
beginner where you have to like be sharp
witted and on your feet especially it's
a kind of debate called parliamentary
debate there's a lot of zingers back and
forth and you're interrupting each other
and and you know some witticisms etc
really cloud genre of debate oh yeah in
the crowd boos and yell at each other
and you have to come up with clever
things to defend yourself did a lot of
that in college and you asked we just do
that on Twitter right the government is
actually internet personally I'm less
more of an introvert but I practiced a
lot to try to be a engaging speaker and
to try to have fun up there
and relax so yeah make me think they
were having you know I really started
speaking but a big turning point for me
was I was getting a class and I was
teaching in class and my other teacher
said that to really look at how stand-up
comedians do it you know just in terms
of how they engage with the public how
they hold themselves make use how they
tell us they're able to tell a story
like a long discourse but also with
interesting kind of a sides and things
like that and then but mostly just like
how to have fun up there you know and so
for me like studying stand-up comics and
seeing how you know just make it fun and
just make it like but also you know you
have you also I kind of really start
really well in your head yeah I just
mostly go up there and have fun you know
that's funny far I had a chance to do a
TEDx talk about four years ago and
before I did it I did a TED I did a
Comedy Store two minute three minute
long stand-up comedy routine here in la
jolla maybe will take you guys there for
the after-hours
on May 8 but we need common standard for
Tina yeah I did a three minute yeah I
did a three minute thing and I said you
know I said if I'm gonna bomb in front
of you know the whole world on Ted I
want to bomb first in front of you know
a couple hundred drunk people
so I actually prefer the the can of
comedy
you know club to to you know the most
lecture halls I mean for one thing
there's a two-drink minimum and that was
really nice to have you know most of my
students only come in one morning that's
right yeah usually they only drink one
drink before they come to class new
insights into pedagogy you know with I
from now on I decided that I'm only
gonna have a bouncer and each one of my
lectures no facebooking and tweeting of
your comics comics one thing I think you
know Jorge you speak a lot of truth in
as I said you know there's a lot of
truth and ennui and an existential dread
in your comics but I think you know if
you were to do that in another form the
way that you do it in the comic form I
think it Rob's it of some of the pain
and actually gives it gives it the ring
I mean add to the ring of truth and I'm
wondering did that always resonate with
you I mean you could have been an artist
you know depicting and more realistic
for I've seen you know very detailed you
know scientific drawings that you've
made and you know so what about the
comic format that appeals to you most I
just think it's magic you know I kind of
grew up early on in my childhood I was
exposed to a lot of comic strips a lot
of comic books and comic collections and
so I just think the whole thing is
really magic you know the way and like
you say you can kind of pass up a little
bit of truth but also and Basket
characters its light-hearted I just
think there's a certain magic magic to
that so are really accepting of it
they're like they're happy to read a
comic and to absorb something from it
it's not a intimidating form of
communication for whatever reason they
associated with childhood or goofy
superheroes or something but there there
are inhibitions there barriers are like
really comics yeah which is one thing
we're gonna thought a good fit for
communicating science because there are
a lot of very understandable ideas we
start telling people I'm gonna tell you
some physics they immediately start
thinking I'm not gonna understand no
make people feel like don't worry you're
gonna get it just stick with us that's
that's a big part of the hurdle did it
simplify things that Hornet had a
technical for you Daniel I mean
explaining science and actually hurry
you've done comics about explaining
science to the public and kind of this
you know I call it this you know instead
of the military-industrial complex it's
kind of the academic academia and
journalism you know companies where
everything has to be really hyped up to
ask me you know huge major breakthrough
in the treatment of toe fungus and that
has to go viral and then of course you
know my pet excessive make you healthier
or you know major find a car right or
yeah or you know so was it work when you
went we're working with Jorge Daniel
like was it easy I mean was it easier
that he had such a strong technical
background as opposed to most
illustrators you you had it probably
would have had to probably explain a lot
more to and did that liberate the
creative bandwidth for you guys to work
to go over that you know that already
had such a strong technical background I
think it was essential yeah um one thing
that I noticed very early on was that he
just never stopped asking questions
until he actually understood I think
part of that was he imagined it was
possible to understand and he wanted to
penetrate through all the layers of
jargon like actually explained sembly
and the first time we hung out we spend
like four or five or six hours talking
about one topic in science he just
recorded the whole thing if you go back
and listen to it you can see this time
when he's like just depressing me and
pressing the impressing movie and so I
think that's what makes it part of it
what makes it successful is that we
really make a connection all the way
down to those accessible ideas and that
was part of the process of our book is
that I would start and write something
which I thought was accessible and I
thought was interesting and I thought
how do I take on it
be like no I don't get it or let's you
know I don't get this first bit in this
first paragraph I explain that more and
that was great like for example we're
talking about gravity and no I doesn't
does about this stuff about spacings
like what what do you mean and let's
talk about that more and that whole
conversation turned into a chapter about
space and that's a great idea
let's just tell chapter what is space
it's a really simple basic question and
fascinating you know all that came out I
found he finally found a professor Jorge
who had to answer your questions this
recording he has at the time he was on
the bus with them the Higgs convener of
Atlas Ilan gross and he's asking him
questions and he's like explain to me
what is symmetry and nilaam is
struggling and this is Ilan gross he's
like he's a good size yeah he's good
speaker and he's like struggling to find
the words and he says things and that
Netflix like you make me invent these
words because you asked me these
questions and that's what I think a good
science journalist should do like
actually insist that things be explained
I think a lot of sense and falls short
of that standard possible partly because
or hey I had a technical background yeah
they probably can't afford to spend four
hours that's right you've got you got
mouths to feed
that's right yeah a tenured professor
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
find Jorge didn't you basically
commissioned him to explain as you felt
these lacunae and the discussion of the
Higgs boson in the early part of this
decade is that correct Daniel that you
base
we just blind pitched Jorge out of the
blue and try to Commission him to work
on an explainer for the Higgs boson yeah
I just cold emailed him I mean I did a
fan for years and my wife has been fan
and actually I read a different tenant
but comic it was a comic about
development the Chrome browser than my
Scott McCloud and like I'm not that into
chrome that how to write a browser but
this comic did a good job of making it
interesting like somebody's in Tolkien
field so I thought well if they can do
that for like developing a browser like
what's the big question there with to
pull the hook right there's nothing then
physics weather I think is a lot of but
I didn't have the artistic skills myself
and so so well I'll just email a
celebrity and see he writes back
cartoonist do you write back when you
offer the money well I tried that with
Banksy but he didn't write back all
right
horray one thing we explore down here in
San Diego at the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination is whether or not
creativity imagination artistry can be
taught and I'm curious both you guys but
first we're hey could you teach someone
to be a good artist can you t if you
just took somebody like me who has no
artistic skills and could you actually
could you do it could you make me into a
[ __ ] hey champ I don't know if you can
see somebody to be an artist but I think
you can definitely you know compel them
to practice a lot and so I would say
that yeah I would say it's mostly about
practice and doing it a lot and but more
importantly having kind of that
perspective of being open and
self-critical and just having that
internal desire to sort of learn to
craft and know what it takes well how to
recognize that people respond to him
yeah yes I'm not quite sure that it's
something you can like really teach but
you can definitely like to tell people
or given an opportunity to do it a lot
one of the biggest advice I give people
is it's like commit yourself to doing it
to somebody like so you have a deadline
so you have a reason so you feel bad if
you don't make the deadline anything for
me like I I think the only reason I
really kept doing it was a student
newspaper and they were actually like
pay me a few bucks so there was a
deadline so I just had to keep keep
churning it out you know mm-hmm so I
think didn't have that deadline it would
probably just never never really produce
anything so then that kid gets into the
habit and then that gets you type design
mm-hmm I know deadlines are important to
Jorge because the only always turned
stuff in immediately before the day
which gives me maximum time to work on
it right segment please for the creative
Daniel can you teach somebody to be a
great physicist need someone to be a
great physicist yeah I hope so
yeah what's your so what would you do I
mean are there things that you could do
to ensure the creativity because I mean
a lot of being a scientist is being
creative and being inventive being an
artist even though you know like you
said we don't really get ever get
training on how to teach we don't get
training at how to do research so how do
you you know it's mostly taught from
advisor to advisee so how do you
inculcate that curiosity the creativity
in your students that's a great question
I think about that a lot because most of
my students are members of the Atlas
collaboration which means we're in a
five thousand person collaboration where
a lot of things have been done for you
and a lot of things have been almost
everything's been done already and if
you're not careful your students can
just fall into a rut repeating something
somebody's done before and not really
learning anything so my group I make a
lot of particular strides to avoid that
and one thing I do is we have this
exercise every six months and we call it
the crazy ideas medium where everybody
has to come in with at least one or two
ideas for a new experiment like think of
a question you want answered about the
universe and then propose experiment no
limitations on cost or practicality or
whatever you know galaxy colliders and
this kind of crazy stuff and then we
think about it we take it we say well
okay how would you do that how much
would it cost would it actually work and
some of my students take to this right
away and they come in with great ideas
and actually our cosmic ray smartphone
tap came out of that meeting where we
somebody suggested this idea and if we
thought about it could we make that work
let's think it through and do the
calculations and we couldn't demonstrate
to ourselves that it wouldn't work so we
decided let's actually try to do it and
other times people had crazy ideas like
let's use the Atlas instrumented area as
a direct detection experiment like we
have a bunch of protons in there and
what if there's a wimp wind maybe
they'll interact we'll see them and so
we did the calculations but the point is
that we I have to specifically poke them
in prod them and some students never
take to it they feel really
uncomfortable and they show up and they
have no ideas and they never suggest
anything so I think some students not
good at it other students can learn if
you poke through and insist and they
they become become good they think you
can learn to think broadly and and relax
your mind yeah mm-hmm
and then I know you guys are on on a
tight deadline today so a couple of
questions to finish up with so one is is
is one that I wondered if you could if
you don't hey if you could pay you know
God or your favorite spirit or you know
whatever to answer one of the questions
one of the chapters except for chapter
13 well which which one would each one
of you both both like you know most like
to know the answer to you mean the book
yeah which would you like to have an
idea and we have no idea that chapters
are all very very provocatively titled
things like who is shooting particles at
the earth what is time what a space what
is gravity
and I'm wondering you know if you got if
you could get an audience with your you
know the creator if you believe in such
an entity or just you know
get the answer you know
sent in an email to you what would you
most of all these questions of all these
great questions which one would you most
like to get the answer to what's God's
email address think see that well I
think I've already sorted chosen because
I decided to dedicate in my life to
particle physics and you know breaking
down matter into smaller and smaller
pieces and you know it's it's sort of
stereotypical or it's a trite story but
I really have been wondering about that
question since I was a kid like what is
everything made out of what is the
smallest particle so to me it's a really
it's the kind of question which you knew
the answer would change the way you felt
about the universe like is there a
smallest thing or do does it go on
forever with smaller and smaller
particles I would love desperately love
to actually know the answer to that
question and it kills me that there is
an answer all right there's a factual
answer and it's out there determined you
just don't know it one day humans might
know it it's a kind of thing that makes
me want to like freeze my head for five
thousand so I can be resuscitated
when we learn the measured you know
that's possible you could conceivably do
that you could fast-forward your way
through scientific progress to the
future and learn the answer to one of
these questions
that's a little bit tempting me
sometimes absolutely it is it's kind of
a tie between are we alone in the
universe so we have a chapter in the
book that kind of talks about the how
people think about the question of
whether there are other intelligent
beings in the universe someone and also
there's a chapter we have about how big
is the universe mad just a question like
is the universe infinitely big or does
it have kind of an edge to it or does it
curve around on itself so I think I
think if
those are the two questions I would love
to have answer and then the last thing
you guys sort of epitomize this you know
there's always this dichotomy that's
spoken about in popular circles you know
the the left brain and the right brain
and I can never remember which brain I
am you know and that probably means that
I'm one of the brains birdbrain yeah my
mom named me brain and only because was
an anagram for Brian hoping it would get
me some extra IQ but but do you see the
arts and science you know as as
reconcilable in the sense that you know
can art influence science can science
influence our we we have a great many of
our patron saint if you will are thirsty
Clark is is of course you know the great
science scientists and a great writer
author what do you see is the future of
these two cultures I mean do you think
they're destined to just sort of meld
together more or you know do you think
the the most fruitful Avenue is perhaps
some sort of union of the two as you
guys have begun to initiate who I have
some thoughts about that I think that I
don't think a union is necessary I think
there's sort of a happy ecosystem where
they support each other and I think
science fiction for example drive
science in a lot of ways I view science
fiction writers is sort of like proto
theorists like you know he's the kind of
world I'd like to imagine could we do
this maybe the world works in this way
right and there's lots of examples where
ideas started in science fiction and
then came actually directly to science
and then the other way you know we
discover something crazy in science and
then there's a bunch of science fiction
about it you know like how many books
are there or now about like hey I take
over
we definitely influence each other um
and on the literary side and on the
artistic side I mean I think one of the
great sources of artistic inspiration is
just the sheer beauty of the universe
yeah you're you're an astrophysics
person like look at the incredible
beauty of the universe and you have to
wonder like did it have to be that way
could we have been humans that evolved
they thought the universe was ugly
because somebody look and these galaxies
and say yuck what a mess right look at
the Grand Canyon and think like oh I
wish this was just smooth and be sure
this
something about being human is it
something about the universe itself I
think a lot of these scientific
discoveries inspire artistic reactions
and also in in science artistic and
aesthetic preferences guide us if you
talk to theorists in particle physics
they say this theory is beautiful that
theory is ugly they prefer things that
have some sort of structure to them that
they aesthetically like that is those
rules and they're aesthetic choices
about how they think the universe should
work that often guides the research we
do so you mentioned in the book Dirac in
a Dirac was guided you know he said you
should be guided by finding you know
it's more important your equations are
beautiful than that they're right a lot
of negative things to say about poets
and and are I think I think he was a
deeply closeted poet and record about
that yeah he wanted to be a poet so
badly that when he failed at it he you
know his consolation prize was the Nobel
Prize but but it still never requital
all right guys good Hori do you have any
final thoughts about the melding of
cultures or do you find inspiration from
science or do you feel like science can
be inspired by art or both well I think
that there's definitely there to have
different goals you know the goal of
science is very different than the goal
of art you know at the core it's about
truth I think but maybe one is more
objective truth and the other one is
subjective truth but I think yeah I
agree with Daniel I think there's a lot
of overlap in terms of inspiration and
imagination and yeah it's just kind of a
personal inspiration to do it yeah at
the end though I think there is sort of
throw there are different but there's
definitely a lot of kind of areas in
between you know yeah absolutely well
guys thank you so much I know you're
super busy today I want to thank you
Jorge Cham and Daniel Weitz and authors
of we have no idea the last hardcover
version I'm gonna get you guys to sign
it when you're here on May 8th and we're
gonna celebrate the release of we have
no idea and paperback
and then talk about what's coming next I
want to see and find out the future of
you guys is Sarah we have no idea to t
oo or number two so we'll see well let's
go I mentioned the website and guess
anyone's interested
we have no idea calm music just we have
no idea and actually we do have a
project coming up which is a podcast
we're launching a podcast to talk about
a lot of things we didn't get to talk
about in the book and other stuff and
it's very humble Daniel and Jorge
explain the universe yucking it up and
so on computer the sinners will be
interested yeah absolutely well we'll
certainly promote that there are our
podcasts we welcome the competition
we're not scared of anything here
that's right girl the pie of what we
have no idea about thank you guys so
much I'm gonna stop lucky thank you